right drew brees is staying in new
orleans eli manning's retired philip
rivers has left the chargers what's the
next domino what are we gonna hear about
next by way of a quarterback making a
deal a trade that's lined up to become
official four weeks from today a
potential free agent or you know tom
brady won't be back with the patriots
what do you think is going to be the
next thing we hear i i mean i feel like
the next thing we're going to hear is
tom brady i do something along those
lines i mean i think there'll be rumors
with andy dalton and cam newton and all
of that but i still think the next thing
we'll know about because like with cam
noon we still have to wait for the the
the uh the physical and all that stuff
right
and i don't think guys like teddy
bridgewater and everybody else are going
to get their situations figured out
marcus mariota
and andy dalton are those kind of guys
until brady kind of gets figured out i
think brady of course is one of the
linchpins here probably followed by cam
newton honestly to see where he goes and
then everybody's going to start to fall
in place but i think it will be brady i
don't know what do you say
well i think what's going to happen is
next week at the scouting combine
brady's agent don yee is going to find
out who is and isn't interested and then
after the combine it'll be time to
negotiate with the patriots and
everybody's going to want to know what's
going on fairly quickly so i think
within the next two weeks
give or take a couple of days maybe
let's say by the end of the week that is
coming up two weeks from now the week
after the combine yeah we'll know
whether or not he's staying with the
patriots he won't know where he's going
but we'll know whether or not he's
staying with the patriots within the
next 16 days and there may be other
dominoes before then but for brady i
think we're gonna know up or down
staying in new england by that friday
that first friday in march yeah well i
mean i just i don't you know at this
point and again i i'm not like reaching
out to any friends in the nfl or people
like that right now quite yet but i just
i haven't heard anything substantial
and i don't know if there's one thing i
can point out to as far as the other
quarterbacks we just showed on that list
here on tv and the graphic of where i
can say ooh that makes sense that's
gonna happen i i don't you know i know
we have some feel for what we think
might happen with phillip rivers and
there's guesses on there but you know
again i don't think there's anything
substantial with any of these guys right
now and i think brady is a huge part of
this conversation to see where everybody
else falls when all said and done
yep and uh look there are plenty of
dominoes that are gonna fall again some
already have more are coming this is
shaping up to be one of the crazy and
i'm not just saying it to hype it
this is i've never seen this many
quarterbacks available as free agents
potentially available in trade or
possibly going to be released and
the stuff's already happening behind the
scenes now the point we made yesterday
for tom curran to even suggest that tom
brady is considering the possibility of
having all the interested team come to
him
they already know there's interested
teams or he wouldn't be there's no
reason to have that thought right right
it would be incredibly presumptuous to
say gee i think i'll have all the teams
that are interested in acquiring my
services come see me oh how many are
interested none well nevertheless once
they become interested they'll come see
me they know they know and why wouldn't
you look it's more than football folks
it's a business they don't want us to
say it's a business it's a business and
it's good for business to have tom brady
you're going to sell out your stadium
you're going to sell your luxury suites
they're people are actually going to
show up for the games they're not going
to be no shows and they're all going to
be wearing their new tom brady number 12
that's right no you're right they are
that's what he does i mean he's that big
of a figure we know that he's an icon
and you're right the quarterback thing
is crazy let alone we think we have
three top five quarterback picks in the
draft and probably another another few
guys who are going to be substantial
starters so quarterback play in the nfl
is as good as it can get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports